we're welcoming back to the rich eisen
show uh but for the first time as a
tampa bay buccaneer
fresh off of a big performance in week
number two
for this team that i have chosen to win
it all i'm not just saying that to
butter up my next guest i truly felt
that way
based on everything that i saw this off
season and his acquisition
uh by the team after jacksonville moved
on surprisingly from him
was kind of like the final uh decision
maker for me he's leonard fournette how
are you leonard
i'm good long time rich how you been i
am well how about you
what's going on with you good man i'm
good you got it so
um when did you hear that you were um
gonna get uh let go by jacksonville
let's start with the last few weeks
before we turn to the current day well
uh man
i didn't hear anything to be honest but
when i was on my way uh
walking up for breakfast to get ready
for practice and stuff and go get ready
to eat
uh one of the guys from the office uh
they told me coach wanted to talk to me
and uh
after that he just released me his words
was uh you know i think i fit this game
i'm more of a guy that needs the ball 20
those times you know
which is cool you know it's a business i
kind of understand that now
my first year and then i fell and uh it
was it's no
it's no harm no hard words no hurt none
of that um
it's a new start from me here at tampa
bay yeah well look
obviously uh you're you're in a pretty
good spot but before we get to that spot
though i do want to linger on this a
little bit if you don't mind
so coach marone told you you were not a
scheme fit
in in releasing you yeah
how did that sit with you uh
i mean you know it was shocking you know
i was shocked uh i i didn't really have
any words to say
to be honest uh i just shook his hand
i would see a couple of players a couple
of coaches before they let me go
and that's about it you know i moved on
of course um now um
[Music]
you're with tampa what were your
decisions what were your choices
when you had one i had a lot i had a lot
i had a lot of talks to be honest
and um i just
felt like tampa was
the the place for me as far as like
the position it was in i think it's
ideal like
tom brady's a quarterback you have guys
like mike evans you have chris you have
gronk
you have you have lashon you have rojo
you have a great line
you have you got you have a hell of a
defense and i said
i can help out even more by coming here
and that was my decision
you know did uh anybody uh
did brady call you while you were making
your decision did he reach out
at any point to say come here or yeah i
mean
i mean a lot of guys just called me off
from all over but
at the end of the day i think
the last the last decision came to me
you know and i felt like
tampa was the ideal choice for me
especially uh
coming from a team that that
so used to eight nine man boxes you know
and i think and i think that's why a lot
of people kind of took my comment
you know when i say about an issue which
i didn't really mean it like that but
what i really meant was like i know time
can help me out a lot
you know i think a lot of defensive guys
defensive schemes but they they uh
they fear that man you know what i mean
he's been playing my phone so
i just think i helped myself out to put
myself in a better situation and not
being forced to ball 27 times again you
know
no i know i i hear you um i'm not a film
junkie
um i've only seen it i only saw it live
but didn't the touchdown you ripped off
to
end the game wasn't that coming with a
bunch of guys in the box leonard
didn't that yeah yeah it was yeah
because uh you know the situation with
the situation was it was kind of like to
end the game yeah of course
we were going to run the ball it was
second to run so yeah
it was yeah i know that's kind of a
specialty of yours you did that against
pittsburgh a few times if i'm not
mistaken back in your
back in your jacksonville days i got
leonard fournette here on the rich eisen
show
so your first impressions of tom brady
and playing alongside the goat would be
what
he's the champion man uh you you love a
god that
who gets frustrated when he makes
mistakes and when i don't to when i say
frustrated i don't mean like
the bad minimum like it hurts him almost
to the fact that he made a bad choice
and that's the type of guys i need
around me and i think absolutely
not just me the whole team better as a
whole
when we can kind of reflect on ourselves
and get pissed at the mistakes we made
and get better from it you know and i've
seen that from time to time
he motivates everyone especially the
offense but i'll keep going
even though we might have a bad drive or
anything everything happens and um
he's just a great motivator to be around
and just in terms of you know not
wanting to disappoint him
as well leonard is that what you're
saying there's that aspect of it
that end and i mean to support yourself
too you know
we all put in the hallway during the
week and just to get ready for
the sunday you know so i think it's vice
versa i think we kind of
expected ourselves to to not to mess up
leonard fournette here on the rich eisen
show um
so you know all of us are focused on
who's start or who's not
what's your relationship with ronald
jones like and obviously with sean
that's a heck of a
of a running back room that you got
right there
yeah i love it man uh rojo he's you know
he's kind of cut so
he's quiet um shitty more of the
outbound type
you know shady shady's funny as hell man
i mean
he keeps the room going i know i'm funny
too and i've been around a lot of funny
guys but
i think shitty got me beat you know and
i said uh
just the vibe of the room you know from
i think this is rojo third our second
year
is my fourth year and it's actually this
is the first time i've ever been in a
room
in the last two years with guys that's
older than me you know like like it was
like
like uh mccoy huh you know last year in
jacksonville
for this year that's i was the oldest
guy man chris thompson
which is so funny because i'm just i
want to go into my fourth year and say
i'm the only guy it was weird you know
you know what i mean it was funny
but i just i love the running back group
you know i think
we can get better as a whole we kind of
help each other with the little things
you know because
you know shady's been been in the league
for a minute and the things he's seen
and the things he's done you know he's
always critiquing us helping us with our
game
now you say it's it's rare for you to be
in a room with someone older
haven't you been in a room with tom
coughlin
yeah i have i have but
uh time wasn't time was the plan at the
time
oh okay see i'm a funny guy too leonard
you know i i guess i that's my
competitive streak when i hear that you
know
you're talking about other people being
funny i'm i guess that was my
competitive streak coming out there
yeah that was a nice one thank you i
appreciate that that's that's kind of
all i'm looking for
so what was the conversation like
between weeks one and two
uh we're all focused on uh aryans and
brady's relationship and
how the offense did not come out looking
like uh
um somebody that was about to win the
super bowl and i
you know obviously it's a work in
progress but what was it like internally
that conversation between weeks one and
two leonard fournette
oh i mean it's a week-to-week thing i've
seen the first um
first week out that was my third day
getting facilitated
you know so i think as time goes goes on
we only gonna get better and better
you know
all right guys and uh you know a lot of
us don't have chemistry like we
like we did like
you know just like just like my dig
still here on my third
whatever it is and i'm still learning
guys still figuring them out
understanding their weaknesses and what
they're good at and what can
of knowing that and he loves the game of
football and i think he's going to do a
great job bringing us guys out to help
us out
in situations like that well leonard
look man
i appreciate the time thank you for
calling in um
and let's do this uh on the regular you
know congrats on
on uh winding up with a team that's got
super bowl qualities and
a place where you still don't have to
pay state tax
yes sir uh-huh and uh and um
and you know uh let's let's uh let's
let's catch up uh mid-season see how
you're doing
if you don't mind well definitely
appreciate you like that you got it you
got it you be well that's leonard
fournette right here on the rich eyes
that show his
phone connection getting a little bit uh
wonky as they say
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here